and and that's also one thing that
scares a lot of people from being an
honest conversation with themselves the
implications of being an honest
conversation with yourself just feel too
massive your only job right now is just
to stay in quiet conversation with that
part of you you don't need to act on it
you don't even know what it means yet if
you just stay in conversation with that
part of you if you just keep listening
to it giving it space giving it
permission that can take you all the way
throughout the rest of your life if you
just stay present to it it will
eventually inform action you may be
scared of it for a while presence has
this pressure cooker type nature to it
and if you shine presence onto the
reality of what's here without numbing
it or suffocating it eventually that
voice The Whisper deeper inside of you
it's going to get louder and more
prominent it's going to move its way
through your conditioning